hi guys my name is Pierre Koenig I'm one
of the game designers of forge of
Empires and today we're going to check
out the brand new Easter event and we're
gonna hobble there right now this is our
city on the test server so the one or
about the plenty of diamonds there and
what is new during the Easter period is
grave oh she's wearing her funny bunny L
suit again which some people of you
might recognize from last year and
exactly like the last year she made the
mistake of going into a bet with ribbon
your gesture and she lost it so she has
to wear this bunny outfit outfit and
your task is to help her and when you
help her then you will get Easter eggs
as a start of the game you already have
25 Easter eggs that's our present for
you and we'll use those Easter eggs
along with the ones that you'll collect
from grewia and collect from your city
to buy really really cool stuff from the
easter egg tradin so you see here there
are a couple of golden egg icons
hovering over some of your decorations
it has to be decoration skies and when
you click on one of those you'll get
some Easter eggs put into your into your
stack so how do you get those Easter
eggs well that is where the other
players come in to come into play
because they have to go and hide those
Easter eggs into your in your
decorations alright so here we are in
the city of another player and as you
can see we have a new social action down
here which is available during the
Easter egg and this is high easter egg
so we click it we choose a decoration
the DA we hit an easter egg and as you
can see up here the number of hiding
action went down by one you actually
have six available and as the forge
points they recover at a rate of one per
hour in the trade and you can get all
different sorts of really really cool
things during the eastern end and as you
can see a couple of them are greyed out
that is simply due to the fact that you
don't have enough Easter eggs yet but
don't worry during the course of the
event of course you're gonna make plenty
of those and you'll be able to get
plenty of the things you want for
instance the old favorites the watch
Fire or the
well or the lock cabin or one of the
really really cool new things like the
champions retreat a military building in
which you can get our new unit to
champion that has actually a really
amazing special skill the call of duty
which we call it that means when this
guy he's a very fast unit he's always on
the front line and when he dies he boots
all the remaining troops in Europe in
your army or you can get the renovation
kit another great item it's put into
your inventory and you can use it from
there to upgrade one of your event
buildings building which you got from a
previous event like the tree of lava for
the graveyard and you can upgrade it to
your current age the chest as you can
see here they held all different sorts
of cool things inside on the right you
see the percentage of how likely it is
that each one will drop when you open a
chest don't worry whenever you open a
chest you get one of the things that's
for guaranteed and the other thing is
only the chance that it will drop so
let's go and open a golden chest and as
you can see a green ribbon appeared up
here in the corner and that is for the
collection reward up here so if you
manage to get during the course of the
event all these things in the Easter
tradin at least once then you unlock the
collection rewarding is put in your
inventory okay folks that's it for our
brand new Easter event feature go check
it out I wish you plenty of luck and
plenty of Easter eggs